[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la soirée de gala qui a réuni à l'Opéra
monsieur Lopez Matteo c'est son épouse
et le président de la République
française et Madame De Gaulle au milieu
des plus hautes personnalités de l'État
a marqué la fin de la visite à Paris du
président du Mexique une visite dont le
général de Gaulle a pu dire qu'elle
était un événement solennel c'est la
première fois depuis quatre siècles que
la France reçoit le chef de l'État du
Mexique
[Musique]
chômeur ont assiégé le Parlement de
Londres en réclamant du travail effet
brutal de la crise économique dont
souffre la Grande-Bretagne avec ses
700100 travail
Manon tu beaucoup de mal à contenir les
manifestants il n'y parvain qu'au prix
d'une lutte sévère
bilan de la journée 10 policiers blessés
et des dizaines d'arrestations
[Musique]
en Pologne où le froid s'accroche on
chasse l'hiver à la grenade
pour accélérer la débâcle de la Vistule
les grands moyens ont été utilisés pour
réduire en miettes ce miroir de 50 cm
d'épaisseur
la glace est rompue mais la marche
tumultueuse de cette interminable sorbet
a été fatal aux vieux pont de bois de
dablyn dont l'une des arches a été
emportée
dernier méfait d'un long hiver qui se
venge ainsi de ce coup de pouce
artificiel donné au printemps
lorsque vous sortez d'une banque avec à
la main une sacoche apparemment rebondi
un bon conseil n'oubliez pas que la
rubrique des faits divers est pleine de
récits de hold-up tous plus audacieux
les uns que les autres filez droit votre
chemin et surtout ne regardez pas en
l'air
[Musique]
cartel est la toute dernière technique
demandant peu de moyens et le minimum
d'investissement que deux jeunes voyous
viennent d'employer en plein Paris à
éviter cependant un premier avril
[Musique]
nos deux énergumènent auraient tout de
même dû y regarder de plus près ils ont
peut-être fait d'un clochard le gagnant
d'un des quelques 65000 lots de la
tranche spéciale de Pâques de la Loterie
Nationale et peut-être du gros lot d'un
million il se passe des choses tellement
curieuses le premier avril
est-ce que encore un prince héritier à
marié dans un royaume lointain il est
vrai au confins de l'un et de la Chine
ces choses faites le maharaja du Sikim a
uni son fils à Miss hobkok ce qui value
au haut de forme de l'Oncle Sam
d'apporter une note pittoresque dans une
vieille cérémonie bouddhiste
[Applaudissements]
dans une pagode richement décorée Miss
pop Cook après avoir absorbé selon la
tradition le thé au beurre de buffle a
reçu des mains de ses nouveaux sujets
des écharpes de soie blancs
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'une charmante
représentante de la société new yorkaise
est devenue princesse du Sikkim
[Musique]
monsieur Marc Jacquet ministre des
Travaux publics et des transports a
officiellement ouvert le nouveau tronçon
de l'autoroute du Sud qui ajoutera 9 km
de béton au 36 déjà en service
[Musique]
une petite consolation pour les
automobilistes que les fêtes de Pâques
lancent traditionnellement sur les
routes et qui en a un endroit de France
doivent compter cette année avec les
méfaits du dégel
Fontainebleau c'est encore un peu
rapproché de Paris c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les beaux jours
[Musique]
et pour l'hiver prochain le pneu neige
vers glace expérimentale vient d'être
présenté à la patinoire de Boulogne nos
trois mois de verglass sont encore assez
proches pour nous faire apprécier cette
démonstration faite avec deux voitures
la première équipée de ces nouveaux
pneus la seconde de pneumatiques
ordinaire et le spectacle de ces deux
même voiture attachées l'une à l'autre
tirant un sens inverse mais dont seul
cette fois-ci encore la blanche est
équipée du pneu neige verglas et
rassurant pour la sécurité de nos futurs
randonnées hivernales
[Musique]
en Angleterre on n'avait rien trouvé
jusqu'à présent pour empêcher les
tracteurs de s'embourber dans la terre
grasse au grand désespoir semble-t-il
des fermiers britanniques qu'ils se
consolent l'un vers kraft vient de
régler leurs problèmes d'une manière
radicale en supprimant purement et
simplement les roues la machine agricole
de demain glissera sur un coussinet
d'air et dire que des siècles durant
l'inventeur anonyme de la roue fut
considéré comme un génie
[Musique]
épine dorsale du Pérou la Cordillère des
Andes domine une vaste région ou vivent
entre 3000 et 5000 mètres les deux tiers
de la population péruvienne il était
donc nécessaire que la route moderne
franchisse cette gigantesque barrière et
que le train lui-même s'y aventure à une
altitude supérieure à celle du Mont
Blanc
centre actif de ces routes terre du
Pérou Puno est aussi le port le plus
haut du monde à 3800 mètres d'altitude
au bord du lac Titicaca ce port assure
le transit vers la Bolivie des
marchandises venus de la côte du
Pacifique c'est aussi un pôle
d'attraction pour les riverains à
l'heure de l'embarquement on y voit
fleurir les chapeaux melons et les
chapeaux mous auxquels certaines
indiennes pourtant continuent de
préférer le chapeau plat du folklore
12 fois la superficie du lac de Genève
le lac Titicaca a de tout un favoriser
l'élevage et les deux y côtoient sur ses
rives les troupeaux de Lama animaux
domestiques à tout faire du Pérou
quant aux pêcheur ils sont restés
fidèles à leur barque ancestrales qu'il
fabrique eux-mêmes avec les roseaux du
lac
avec ses étonnantes embarcations il
pêche des truites géantes certaines
mesures jusqu'à un mètre 30
étrange pays où il semble tout à coup
que le temps se soit arrêté en 1911 on
découvrait au sommet d'une montagne les
ruines d'une ville Machu Picchu déjà
abandonné du temps des Incas et vieille
peut-être de 6000 ans on y retrouve un
observatoire du soleil sur lequel les
archéologues continuent de s'interroger
et une immense pierre où était sacrifiée
des victimes humaines au dieu du soleil
plus proche de nous le souvenir des
Incas par contre est resté vivant les
mines d'où il faisait extraire l'or et
l'argent fabuleux sont encore en
exploitation
offlant des montagnes sur les mêmes
terrasses qu'il firent bâtir il y a des
siècles se perpétuent aujourd'hui les
mêmes cultures étagées
les méthodes agraires sont restées
identiques même organisation collective
et pour cultiver la pomme de terre dont
ils sont les vrais inventeurs toujours
la même arrêt de bois
ancienne capitale de l'empire Inca Kuzco
est elle-même aujourd'hui la synthèse de
deux civilisations chaque maison en
témoigne sur un rez-de-chaussée un cas
aux pierres imbriquées pour résister au
tremblement de terre les conquérants ont
tout naturellement élevé un premier
étage à l'espagnol
[Musique]
et dans les scènes de la rue le prêtre
apparaît comme le conseiller écouté au
milieu des descendants du peuple inca
converti au catholicisme les Indiens de
la montagne ont gardé dans l'expression
de leur nouvelle foi le même respect
craintif que leurs ancêtres
manifestaient à l'égard du dieu du
soleil
symbole même de la double hérédité de
Cusco le Christ monumental domine les
restes gigantesques de la forteresse de
saxa waman qui fut le théâtre de la
dernière bataille des Incas et des
conquistadors mais si l'on sait qu'au
pied de ce trône les troupes défilaient
voici cinq siècles devant l'empereur du
soleil on ne sait toujours pas comment
purent être amenés et dressés ces blocs
pesant plusieurs dizaines de tonnes ici
le présent partout se mélange au passé
et à ces mystères
[Musique]